a cold war political thriller directed
by Steven Spielberg starring Tom Hanks
yeah who would not sign up for that sign
me up for that bridge of spies sir
bridge of spies is directed by Steven
Spielberg stars Tom Hanks Tom Hanks
plays an Insurance lawyer no one likes
lawyers insurance lawyers least of all
but Tom Hanks has this monologue at the
beginning where he breaks a case down
against someone else you're like yeah
alright I'm on your side Tom Hanks I am
now I would have been just on the fact
that you're Tom Hanks so long story
short in the cold war blood this movie
takes place in 1960 we find a Russian
spy Tom Hanks is the one who ultimately
takes the case and has a defend this guy
that is a smallish section of the movie
I thought that was gonna be the whole
movie it's not because then the Russians
find one of our spies ultimately the guy
who defended this Russian spy Tom Hanks
needs to organize and orchestrate the
swap of our spy for theirs it's just
it's very convoluted very volatile
because it's the Cold War it's called
bridge of spies takes place in the cold
where you think it's supposed to be like
spies and US vs. damn you know and we're
doing James Bond not like that no
one's shooting anybody no one's actually
doing the espionage it really is a
negotiation movie and that's what the
movie is and Steven Spielberg once again
shows he can take a premise like that
and make it incredibly interesting I'm
watching this moving I'm like I love the
dialogue in this movie Tom Hanks has
more than a couple of very quotable
monologues one of which is what makes us
Americans I loved it
I love the delivery Tom Hanks his
character is so in control but you know
he's a complete fish out of water in
this scenario but he's rolling with the
punches and he's determined to get this
done and have the best outcome possible
for everybody I love Tom Hanks his
characters vigilance and fortitude in
this movie this dude is taking on a case
where he's ultimately defending a
Russian spy people in America think he's
a piece of they're just like you're
a dick why aren't we hanging him you're
an you're helping him but he
just feels like I everyone deserves a
shot and the guy's not a traitor stop
calling him that because he actually has
served his country well he didn't betray
America
he is Russian he's working for them he
actually did his job it kind of reminded
me of the HBO miniseries John Adams if
you haven't seen the HBO miniseries John
Adams you should it's very excellent at
the beginning of that miniseries these
redcoats did something and now
they're on trial no one wanted to defend
them to like yeah just hang him shoot
him whatever John Adams is the lawyer
that takes their case because he's like
everyone deserves a shot just find that
very objective when people do that like
I'm clearly against them but I'll defend
them because they deserve to be heard
they deserve a fair shot like anyone
else that's what I loved about this Tom
Hanks's character sees it this way and
this movie ultimately presents it this
way it's not country versus country
border versus border it's just it's a
movie about humanity's us winning
against the Russians in this deal that's
not the thing that's important to Tom
Hanks was important to Tom Hanks is
humanity treating people with human
decency it's a very important message
specially in today's day in Asia I'm
glad it came across in the movie and I
love the little Russian spy in this
movie he's just unassuming old guy in a
couple times I mean this guy's facing
the electric chair Tom Hanks is like are
you scared the guy's just like what did
he'll I wish I saw things that way I
don't but I can tell if I were that
column and saw things in that
perspective I would be happier
interestingly enough this movies written
by the Coen brothers but I never once
felt like it was a Coen Brothers movie
kind of shows that if person a risin
movie person B directs the movie it's
more gonna feel like person B's movie I
don't know if you're gonna love that or
hey that's just worth addressing because
I found it fascinating guys in the end I
didn't know what to expect with bridge
of spies Steven Spielberg awesome Tom
Hanks great let's see what it is
turns out it's very fantastic great
characters great dialogue great tension
two two and a half hour drama for sure
but it's all negotiation in the Cold War
which is a very fascinating time in
history Steven Spielberg really brought
it with him so I don't think I'm gonna
watch this movie all the time sorry I'm
gonna sit around earlier I really want
to watch bridge of spies you know two
and a half hour negotiation movie they
can't deny the talent behind it I was
thoroughly entertained for the two and a
half hours I will say bridge of spies is
worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray alright guys so bridge of spies
have you seen it what did you think
about it personally I felt it was the
movie to see this weekend and what is
your favorite cold war based movie
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more